hello welcome back to big mood everybody
and i'm just going to start this right
off because i
just have this much confidence that
you're going to like this episode that
i'm going to ask you to like this video
right now if you're watching on youtube
and write us on itunes if you're
listening on audio also if you're
watching on youtube can you go ahead and
download this episode so it looks like
you're listening on audio as well
that is just a big favor right now i
need to help with the algorithm
so like you interacting with the video
really helps like it would just really
help us yes
plus we're going to give you some like
really good information and we have a
guest today
one of our favorites we got nikki blades
in the house
hi what's up mickey she smells like
wifey material she's amazing smells
looks sounds um
all my credit cards i want to take a
bath in your essence all right oh
that's that's i would bathe in your used
bath water i want to watch you
from outside your window just clipping
your toenails i might like that we can
i might like she's gonna have toenails i
imagine looking glitter windows
at like a house that's on a hill and i'm
looking through the window and i see
nikki blaze she has no clothes on her
tits are kind of hanging down and she's
clipping her toenails and i'm like
i will be there to collect them
afterwards i will i want to catch them
again in my mouth i just want to be on
the floor just
catch them again i didn't know i wanted
all these things to happen in my life
but apparently i found out i got some
new kinks going on
did you miss that i did i love you guys
i'm coming back on the show
the audience we we did the set for you
because we were like we cannot have this
level of person in our studio in our
trash set
right i was so excited i was two hours
early yes
yes i was so happy when i saw you that
you were here before your call time i
was like yes we get to hang out with her
longer
yeah she was here before like three of
us yeah she was our audience on the last
episode
she opened up she has the key yeah like
walking to work i knocked on the door
and everybody was looking at me like
who's knocking i'm like
hi i was yelling at the door
because i saw gina as i was walking in
and i was like okay she's about to come
in
and then there was a knock and i was
like who is it you're not welcome here
him early i just didn't text me back and
i was like [ __ ] you better have brought
cleaning supplies
i'm like i only brought clothes and
makeup
i make i clean up myself for you gina's
really sensitive today
crying outside and then walk away so i'm
gonna be like i quit
and i've never even started yet
let me be nice give me a hug okay well
these mics are in the way when we're
done
yeah welcome back we're glad you're back
oh thanks for having me i feel like i've
just
been trying to infiltrate your your
guys's activities for a while
you can't infiltrate what's willing you
can't penetrate what's
so last time you were on the show we
pretty much just talked about your life
and stuff got to know you but i
remember you mentioning money money
and then you were pretty woke about
finances and stuff and i was like oh we
have to bring you back on for another
finance episode because people have been
requesting it since we
did our last one and um you specifically
had mentioned on the episode that if you
have six months of savings
yes that it's a game changer a life
changer yeah and i wanted to talk more
about that as well as other
just basic money management because i
feel like nobody [ __ ] tells you this
[ __ ]
and you don't really think that you need
to learn it until you go through
something where you're like man i wish i
would have known that
yeah um so i want to help all of you out
there
money is probably the thing people
stress out the most about
um they get anxiety over relationships
end because yeah
number number one thing that breaks up
relationships
so instead of that happening let's
prevent it
or if you're already in some troubles
let's help you get out of it
um so what like drove you to
that strategy of keeping i know you said
you're your mom
so my grandma one of the first books i
got was from my grandma and it was about
money management oh that's a good woman
yeah my grandma put me i remember
it was the one of the first books i
remember
reading do you remember what book it is
i have no clue it was like
middle school high school um definitely
like elementary
wow really really really early was it
for kids
no it was i mean there was there was
pictures in it she was like [ __ ] you're
gonna
understand money yeah so my grandma so
my grandma
like took pride in being financially
independent
we love grandma yeah she owned homes i
mean she got her own set of issues trust
me and believe that's a whole nother
episode
but on finances we really like gigi so
um
because she was a diva and never wanted
to be called grandma so
i want to be her already same i don't
know my grandma wasn't she was cece
never wanted to never want to be called
grandma yeah but her
whole thing was being able to take care
of yourself absolutely she wanted to
make sure
and my mom and my dad and they wanted to
make sure that we never needed anybody
for anything so she kind of had
these golden rules it was always the
make sure you have savings
it was to know how to spend money we
always played like cash register
and store and bank like a lot of games
like that can you imagine like
four-year-old nikki when she gets her
lunch money she's like is this tax
oh my goodness i need to know i need
attention i need to know
you know i wish i was better at math i
understand money more than
actual math itself if that makes sense
like i understand like i understand the
concept of money way more than
math so she had like you have to have a
car that can run
like a car that can run a good mattress
that you can sleep on
and enough money to be able to put gas
in your tank so you can go anywhere and
you'll never need anybody
those are good ground rules yeah really
and i've pretty much
lived by those always making sure i have
enough money to put gas in my tank to go
anywhere i need to go and to take care
of my car so that i never
need anyone because you can live in your
car right yeah so you can if you have to
you can
you can so when it came to finances
she was divorced twice but like money
was
i don't know if it was a generational
thing or just how it was
and for her a lot of like marrying up i
think was a
marrying up and marrying for money i
really believe it's kind of a
generational thing i feel like
back in the day so many people did that
um as a survival tactic not everybody
but yeah
women didn't really have i mean
education
yeah this wasn't a long time ago at all
right so
for her she was like hell no that's not
what you're gonna go through she's like
we're not gonna let you have that
because you ain't gonna need to make
sure she's not paving the way
man my grandma was on that i used to
help her with her bills she taught me
how to use the computer you know that
was back when
we were still learning how to use them
she was like nope you're gonna get on
here i helped her with that
you're doing quick books for her pretty
much no no for real
i literally helped her with her
quickbooks wow like doing debits and
credits
yes so everything was always like a
lesson i wasn't the most like
loving household as far as like
that was her love we didn't have balance
yet yeah oh it's all the way off it's
like i don't know about money i
got no idea to have a relationship i
don't know how to say sorry
no but my checkbook yeah yeah i was like
i don't need you for nothing i could
take care of my own ass i know how to
make good credit scores and
yeah but also that comes with a lot of
[ __ ] later in life so
but she was very like she had to make
sure i knew about properties
and so great she had several cars she
made her own money
she had her own issues but financially
she put me up on game that's great so
did you just grow up implementing it
right
right away right off the bat we were
broke so
for us when we moved i moved from hawaii
to california
and we moved in with my grandma so we
moved in we went from an expensive state
to an expensive state
yeah right yeah but you should have just
kept going to nevada
driving somehow my cousins ended up in
california city which is
was supposed to be a bigger like way
bigger than what it was supposed to be
so she bought land out there and then
bought landed newman
so that's how i ended up in california
city california city out by mojave
boron i pictured them having like a
little golden gate bridge
it was supposed to be like this big boom
it's like one of the biggest
land masses like biggest cities in
california and it's in the desert
and it never fell through but we moved
up and
we grew up very much not in a good
financial situation
i've always had to learn how to be
obedient because when you're not the one
that's paying you have to do certain
things and the whole goal was to just
not
live that way and the rule in the house
was until you're paying the bills
you have to do what you're told yep and
so the goal is
to pay your own bills yep and to have
nobody telling you what to do
so until that day comes when somebody
says clean guess what you got to do
clean pick up a broom when somebody says
like you can't stay here you can't eat
this or you can't do that guess what
you ain't got no say so the whole
mission in life was to get to that point
yeah to where you don't have to answer
to nobody i feel like i missed that
lesson because
my my dad raised me um and we were very
very poor as well
but like he never made like wasn't he
was never like
clean your room and i was like no and he
was like well i pay the bills so you
know like i never got that
so i never got that life i never got
that lesson
um but i feel like either you do it or
you get your ass beat right yeah i never
yeah i never
i never got any of that but it wasn't
quite that far i was terrified i have
i think i've gotten that lesson as an
adult like dating men with money that
now want to be my dad i'm like excused
now it's like i like you tell me what to
do because i let you
yeah yeah yes my dad's golden rule
and i swear oh one day it came full
circle it was
i paid like until you got the money
until you man that's what he would say
until you a man
you got to do what you're told and one
day i ended up taking over the phone
bill
nice so back in the day my mom had to
pay for all of our phones and the rule
was if my dad calls you have to pick it
up
why because he pays it you don't pay for
the phone bill
so one day i ended up taking over the
phone bill
and when that man did not pick up his
phone how cute
i told him i pay the bill
you pick up the phone when i call you
and he laughed and to this day
if he doesn't if i give him money it
comes with stipulations
and nobody asked me for [ __ ] now because
i'm like i'm like i take four
good way to make sure they don't ask for
[ __ ] i mean like my brother needs money
and i'll help
but when you ask there's a lesson like
we're no we're doing an itemized receipt
like what are you spending my money on
yeah
you're lucky i don't charge you interest
what do you want to do and then they're
like [ __ ] i'm gonna just get my own
money i'm like
from somewhere else yeah they're like
[ __ ] i don't want to ask nicole or nikki
because my family calls me nicole wow
yeah that's my own trouble name only
kalei if i hear that is that your middle
name oh kale nani
oh i am [ __ ] yeah somebody says that
i'm hiding
yep hiding like same you're the hairs on
your arm going oh yeah i send you a
voice message in the middle of the night
oh
kalei do you want to give her ptsd
i can i can feel my dad like you need to
throw something at me
but yeah so you see that my dad's vein
popping out of his forehead oh my gosh
yes and it was you know how i deal with
money and how my sister and my brother
deal with money we all deal with
our finances very differently my mom
does my dad everybody's very
how did that happen so my sister she's a
middle child and i do believe middle
children have their certain things that
are just very different than the oldest
i'm the oldest
i'm a stereotypical older sister the
firstborn i'm
paranoid about everything i'm such a mom
like it's terrible
my sister is very go with the flow and
it happens it happens and then my
brother is the baby
and he's always gonna do [ __ ] yeah yeah
i can't handle that i can't handle it
but my my sister had a fear of not
having so
i knew we didn't have my sister had a
fear of not having so she didn't really
have the full concept of like we don't
really have the money but my mom
would pick on my sister and would play
like a mean joke and
get to the cash register and be like oh
my god
we don't have enough money and so like
in my head i'm going
yes we do and i'm like i'm like because
we do it i'm counting
yeah like i just put in the income right
i was like no i rounded up uh
so that we can factor in taxes but my
sister would start crying because she
just like
nev like she had a fear of not having
i had the we'll make it work you know
what i mean it'll be like let's take
stuff out
like the facts right she's like oh my
god taking something out of the cart
no like no i can't do it like so my
sister's very aware
of the public image of money and kind of
like the idea of that like shame of
when you don't have enough do you think
that she's not wise with her money
because she's worried about
appearing not having i think it has made
her more
aware of her choices so that she never
she never lives outside of her means so
that she doesn't have the fear
right because she doesn't want to be
denied you know what i mean like i've
definitely
dealt with the overdrawn card i had the
[ __ ] up car
you know uh forgot to do my registration
like i i've
definitely gotten myself in trouble
stupid taxes stupid [ __ ]
you know what i mean i thought you were
gonna go the other way with her because
yeah this is the situation i see
a lot of especially in los angeles is
like people don't have the money to be
buying it but they can put it on a
credit card
oh no and then they're like oh it's only
30 a month for this like
yeah 3 000 thing and then they do enough
of that because they want the image of
keeping up with everything she made sure
she never
got denied at the at the cash register
so she that made her like she was super
paranoid about it she got good credit
she oh yeah we all got good credit yeah
it's a good fear to have it's a good
fear yeah
healthy fear i'm one of those i was like
nah i can factor it in i have no problem
taking out or being like nah
i get buyer's uh remorse instantly i
hate
shopping for myself for certain things i
get that with clothes
i'm not a clothes person so i get buyers
remorse every time i go on a shopping
spree i'm like okay i need new clothes
i've been wearing the same
[ __ ] for like six months or a year the
same [ __ ] like
10 outfits and then i immediately get
buyers remorse and like why didn't i buy
them
and are you the type to budget out like
what you can spend no no
i'll give myself like i almost have to
say i'll force myself to be like cool
you can you can spend this much
on frivolous [ __ ] so i but i go but i'm
reckless with food
so i won't go safe yeah i won't go
shopping like i won't buy shoes i won't
go shopping i won't buy new [ __ ]
but i'll cash out on food yeah yeah my
priority experience
i love it yeah i love it and alcohol
needs to stop being so damn expensive
i don't drink cheap alcohol no when i
was broke broke i had bloody mary's all
the time on hand because it was like
having a salad and a drink at the same
time
i can't afford both calories yeah yeah
yes i got my veggies in and i got my
alcohol
like there's vitamin a in this beta
carotene
all of that i caught myself needing to
stop drinking every time the alcohol was
free
oh right like you know when you hit a
point where you're like man i'm not
poor anymore yeah i don't know i don't
accept everything right
but there's something that's in you that
knows if it's free yeah you gotta take
it you grow up like that
or even like if you're in your 20s and
you move out and you're broke like yeah
yeah there's a scavenger lifestyle that
i don't think leaves you
no oh i keep my supply of like certain
there's certain food that i'll never
not eat because i it's just like
nostalgia first off
i know how to make ramen so many
different ways yeah so many different
ways i make bomb fried noodles okay you
can stay in our group
yeah bomb fried noodles we can still eat
poor like we know how to eat more
it's so good it's still good not healthy
but it's good i caught myself going and
shopping at uh winco it's kind of like a
like a costco i live in the valley so we
have bigger bigger places right
it's like a whole food a whole sale type
of place
okay and i realized i had a problem
when there was the blue box mac and
cheese and then they had the winco brand
mac and cheese and it looks the same but
it was cheaper
and i realized i always grabbed the
knockoff brand of everything
like i just could not bring myself to
buy the name brand stuff there's just
certain things that i have to go
cheaper with and i would always get
called out by like
exes and stuff like the past
relationships they'll be like you're so
[ __ ] cheap yeah
yeah it adds up but then they'll be like
but you just spent two
hundred dollars on food what is wrong
with your business
they're like you can't buy macaroni and
cheese but you'll buy it
you because i do that all the time
our nikki yeah she's like why are you
complaining about this five dollar bank
charge when you just spent like a
hundred and ten dollars on a bottle of
liquor or whatever she's like yeah i
didn't hear you yeah
when we were redoing
brushes and she was comparing the
rollers because one was like
1.99 yeah one was a dollar forty five or
something
for example those are the most crucial
decisions
that's why i like your grandma's role of
like what's the when you get down to the
the very bottom of everything your
foundation like what are your ground
rules
always have a car that runs that that
was a huge lesson
because i didn't take care of my car
when i first moved out here and
then the maintenance fees of like trying
to repair damages over time is way more
you got to get those oil changes
you've got to do that that's how my
first car died because i was too broke
to get all cheese and i thought it would
be okay
no no it's not okay okay yeah so you
gotta put that stuff in the in the gas
the cleaner yeah yeah my dad always made
sure he's like did you put
the [ __ ] in the tank and i'm like oh i
forgot yeah like it's been like four
months put the [ __ ] in the tank
shout out shout out to the parents who
teach their daughters and sons because
some of y'all boys don't know just
because
you know how to deal with a car too many
men have no idea how to fix it
back in the day men knew how to build
houses fix cars
that's why women didn't talk back to
them yeah because they were men
now you deserve it yeah but if i slap
this around
but shout out to the parents who
actually teach their kids how to use
[ __ ] and be [ __ ] like actually do
things like check your oil check your
tire pressures you know
but yeah going no one taught me [ __ ] oh
my dad yo my dad raised me
to be the son that he never had until
later
oh and your brother is it's the only boy
and he's a young
he my brother was the first boy out of
so out of my dad's like side of the
family the first boy out of eight girls
the little prince oh kahua that's my
brother's name my brother's name is cool
okahana mm-hmm that is so crazy yeah he
it means like karma pretty much the
cause and effect of life but he was the
first boy
and i felt bad he had to live in yeah he
had to live in my shadow so i was the
you know very athletic a lot of the
other things but me and my brother have
a really dope relationship
he didn't hold the resentment towards me
so it was cool but yeah the car has to
be able you got to know how to take care
of your car so you
never need to stay anywhere yeah i mean
like you never have to be desperate
enough to crash somewhere you don't want
to crash
and then when you get to the points
where you have a place there's something
so important about having a good
mattress my grandma's like that's where
you spend most of your time is sleeping
we're actually sponsored by a couple
different mattress companies and they're
all
fantastic but we're not talking about
them today today we're talking about
our other sponsors who are very thankful
for tiff i'm hungry
you're hungry gina i can help you
because doordash
is here to the rescue and you can
continue supporting restaurants
in your community safely there are
thousands of restaurants open for
delivery on doordash that need your
patronage
now more than ever support your favorite
restaurants on doordash
doordash is the app that brings you food
you're craving right now
right to your door ordering is super
easy you just open the door dash app you
choose what you want to eat and your
food will be left safely outside your
door with the new contactless
delivery drop off setting you can
support your local go-to's or you can
order from your favorite national
restaurants like
chipotle i can't say it without saying
it in your accent you have to say it
it's about like where is it where's the
wednesdays okay
first restaurants like chipotles and
wednesdays
and my personal favorite cheesecake
factory
it's just too fun to not say like that
but yeah many of your favorite local
restaurants are still open for delivery
so just open the door dash app select
your favorite local restaurant and your
food will be left at your door
doordash deliveries are now contactless
to keep your communities
safe i've been saying it over and over
again because it's an important point to
point out
i would not be a liar i would not be
alive right now if i didn't have
doordash
yeah same girl well if i don't have
casey for sure but
doordash is the backup casey because
casey cooks for me great
gamers great for gamers beautiful
solution to get your food
yours your belly fed that's what i'm
trying to say so right now our listeners
can get five dollars off and zero
delivery
fees on their first order of fifteen
dollars or more when
you download the door dash app and enter
code big mood that's
five dollars off and zero delivery fees
on your first order when you download
the doordash app
in the app store and enter code big
mood don't forget that's code big mood
for five dollars off your first order
with
doordash new year new me guys
oh my god we love it
we love pretending that we're gonna go
to the gym for 30 days
no i'm kidding you know that's the real
problem though i feel like is that
people
set goals then they have no idea how to
reach them right
they have like this grand idea at
midnight
on january 1st and they say i'm going to
stop eating sugar forever
i'm going to get big huge thick thighs
in the gym by doing a ton of squats and
then you know those goals
those goals eventually fail because
there's really no like changing your
habits is like a psychological thing
it's not about just
having grandiose ideas about what you
would like to look like
in 2021 well guys we have been sponsored
by noom i think this is a program that
can help
actually reach your goals this year
based in science and built by
psychologists
noom doesn't give you rules but instead
teaches you how to think
so you can accomplish your personal
health goals and stick with them long
term and actually get healthy this year
not pretend like you're going to be
healthy for two weeks and then drop
it oh yeah um there's like
think about specific goals that you have
like for me i notice um
maybe i want to fit into my clothes
better because i bought them last year
now all of a sudden they're a little
tight and i'm like wait excuse me
and also i just get more sleepy like
when i get more unhealthy and i keep
eating so much sugar and i get more sad
and i just feel unhealthy and like crap
and i start hating myself
i think there's a psychology behind why
i do that and
i think i it helps nume helps
you figure out what is going on in your
life that maybe you're ignoring or what
you need to focus on
what can help you get healthier habits
into your daily life everyone is busy
i mean we're all busy we all have stuff
to do even if we ignore it and we
pretend like we don't got stuff to do we
all got stuff to do
noom doesn't ask for much they only ask
for 10 minutes a day you can log in for
10 minutes a day if you really care
about your health
you can you can do it you can stick to
it there is a science to getting
healthier it's called new
sign up for your trial today at noom
that's n-o-o-m
dot com slash big mood learn how to get
healthy with noom
sign up for your trial today at noom
that's n-o-o-m.com slash big mood
are you ready to live healthier in 2021
sign up for noom today at noom that's
noom.com
big mood i just glanced over before we
started and you were actually on robin
hood
what were you checking out on robin oh
my sucks you were checking out your
stock yes
when when did you get into stocks uh i
want to say like in
april april yeah did you guys pick up
any new
trades yeah i made 88 off paypal
um why because they charged me so many
fees
first of all they own venmo all as well
and then they doesn't charge fees they
own honey
well then use value it's a great it's a
great i know i didn't know that i owned
and they just got into bitcoin although
you don't technically own the bitcoin
it's the whole thing but i think they're
working all the kinks out
that's another that's a whole separate
conversation yeah so actually we'll get
there at the end of this i wanted to
the first half we were talking about
kind of the why like your mindset and
like why you should
care about money management now i want
to get into the how and it sounds like
you have a pretty good system
um can you talk to like basically your
beginner self like if you were to tell
yourself right now this is how
you set your life up financially what do
you kind of do to budget or to
you said you have like um kind of a
budget for close or whatever
yeah um how do you how do you set that
up how do we start yeah where do you
start one of the main things was
figuring out
what my priorities were and what needs
yes
like what actually needs money i needed
to know what my cost of living was
the first thing you need to do is figure
out how much it costs for you to live
your life and that's your base because
every decision you make
you have to cover these things these
things are undeniable you need to pay
your rent you need to pay your car
insurance you need to pay
you know your automobile payment your
health like writing out
how much it costs for you to live every
day should everybody should know their
cost of living
yes and then once you've done that you
need to figure out how much you're
currently making mm-hmm
and do they match because if that cost
of living is way over what you're making
yeah
yeah then you're able to add subtract
kind of find out what's working what's
not working and then once you have that
number as far as
what you're making then you can go and
see this is what i have left or this is
what i need to make
now i think those are the basics that
everybody should know
and it's really surprising how many
people don't know what their cost of
living like at the end of the month
they're like
i don't have enough it should be a
surprise every month it shouldn't be no
it shouldn't be that should be one of
the first things you do because then you
can figure out
what you're saving for you can figure
out how much you want to spend to go out
like what makes you happy
and prioritizing happiness over like
basic finances like no that's how you
end up in debt
you know like yeah your friends are
going out every weekend yeah they're
eating like there's a lot of things i
sacrificed
and i'm happier that i gave up some
nights i'm happier not
that i didn't spend money on certain
things and i look back and i built a
savings
yes but i built a savings the first 10
000
i made that i saved up i knew i wanted
to get a new car because i was driving
um
a pontiac fiero okay so i had not even
heard of that car
it's a little two-seater it was it
almost looks like a ferrari ferrari put
them out of business because i had like
an engine in the back i still have it my
red rocket
my red rocket so 500 off ebay and i
bought her
um i bought it when i was in college
500. yeah i bought it for ebay
yeah thank you yeah [ __ ] that [ __ ]
should have exploded
it actually drove for 500. oh yeah
i can't imagine spending five that's how
far i've come up with my life because i
can't imagine i bought
two cars i had bought a mercury cougar
and then that one the engine fell out i
don't know
any of these cars mercury a mercury
cougar and then i bought a pontiac
both are gone right yeah these brands
don't
make them anymore oh my god when i was
in college i didn't get given a car like
i was driving my parents car for a bit a
minute but then when i went away to
school
they were kind of like yeah yo we you
know your sister you got other siblings
we need that yeah yeah
so i thugged it out bought me a car you
know a 500
car and my dad always told me dudes
ain't going to trip off of what car
you're driving no like they're really
not going to care especially not
you right my dad was
because they're like let me help you can
i check your oil
for you you're like girl i'll put you in
a better car right so
so my dad was kind of like man i'm glad
you got a car but i got it specifically
because my dad had a similar one like it
so i i got a car
that's cute but so i thugged it out but
then i started working in nightlife so i
got into um
like the nightlife scene at like 21 and
that's when i really started getting
money and the first thing i did when i
started
getting money was i started putting
money aside i wanted there were a list
of things that i wanted i wanted an
apartment i wanted a car and i wanted to
just make sure like my teeth was good
yeah let's just repeat that again for
the people in the back when she started
making money it aside
yeah i did not do that i did not do that
i still have the first two thousand
dollars i
got from my graduation oh
so my savings so my savings started with
my graduation money that's so good good
for you
yeah also like i i couldn't get a
scholarship that i wanted i
didn't have parents being able to pay
for my schooling i had to go
and do like when i went to school it was
to go and
sports helped me out so i always knew i
was not getting the best
end of the deal with all of this and i
was going to struggle but i
feel like now looking back at the time i
was like really
bummed about it but now looking back i
feel like adversity
is what helped us in the long run
build those systems and know like how to
take care of ourselves and stuff
totally so when i finally you know got
out of school got into modeling so i
like moved out i was in merced and then
i moved out
um and i started working in the bay area
but i was commuting like my whole thing
was
i needed to stack this money up because
i wasn't living the life that i wanted
to live because remember
if you ain't paying the bills you have
somebody to answer to
and my parents made it real
uncomfortable for me but they always
told me i can come home which was the
best part
but they wanted to always make sure that
i was going to be okay on my own yeah
and which which i was so when i got my
first like i started really saving my
money i got the things that i wanted
then once i got the things i wanted
there was a new list of things that i
needed to get
so it was like prioritizing what was
important but i had a problem with
spending money and one of the things i
wanted to do the next goal after that
first 10 was to get
good credit yeah i was always told like
yes
cash rules everything around you but
credit rules the world like there is
there it's undeniable i mean unless
you're a billionaire
unless you're a billionaire you're a 10
millionaire right or paying everything
in cash
in order to buy bigger things or to make
big purchase items you need
good yeah so building your credit takes
time and i don't think a lot of people
understand the amount of time it takes
to build good credit
especially when you do dumb [ __ ] like
get a credit card
from macy's and not pay that [ __ ] those
department stores credit cards
are the words yeah and they close them
so fast if you don't use them and that
hurts your credit
too totally so it was i didn't get a
credit card right away and i was lucky
with that but i did have
medical bill i had a hospital bill that
ended up yeah i had a hospital bill that
ended up screwing me over
but my my next goal and i really feel
like i hit my like stride with my credit
recently is it was to get that score up
i think i have like a
778 right now nice thank you yeah you
know but it's still
so it's so finicky like learning just
learning about credit itself they
that's a whole course yeah that they
don't teach you
they don't teach you that if you pay off
a card and it closes
that's negative they don't teach you
that when you pay off your car
yeah you close that's a big one that's a
big negative
you need a certain amount of debt um in
order to sustain good credit
yeah and paying everything off and being
that zero isn't necessarily good
because it's proof of your habits it's
almost like counter-intuitive like but
i don't want debt but it's like you kind
of need to kind of well they don't tell
you that you're going to stay in the
system
which most of us are 90 of us are going
to stay in the system and
and need a loan for a house need a loan
for a car yeah then you have to play the
game right yeah
and it feels like the next goal i had
after getting my basics out of the way
to where i wasn't driving my bucket
anymore
so wait before we go to that to help
build your credit um without getting
into massive amounts of debt
um once you know your income and expense
ratio
then you know how much what you're
paying for in cash
so instead of paying your utilities with
cash you can just put it on a credit
card
have it on auto payments then you're
already you are already going to pay
those utilities
and now it's getting you're building
your credit it's getting paid off every
month you're not holding a balance
so my rule is just to never put anything
on credit card that i don't have the
cash to back up for
and if you don't know how much cash you
have to back up for then you need to go
back to step one totally and that's
something that nobody really
teaches you or tells you like i started
paying my rent on my credit card
yes so i pay my rent on my credit that's
a lot did you get that
for that no so i have places charge a
fee and i'm like oh i'm not paying 30
dollars
i finally i finally got to point you
know and technology
yo technology has come such a long way
there's an app now right like there's
apps or you have to do you know whatever
when they finally got an
app um that allowed the processing and
was like oh you can pay with your credit
card i was like
this is amazing so i finally got myself
to the point to where i have an amex
that i'm like cool i'm happy i worked my
way to get this card
i know getting in amex is like oh i got
good credit right
that's why you go like this this is a
charge card i don't know what a charged
card
is a regular credit card for those of
you that don't know you have to pay off
every month
yeah you make charges on it and you pay
it off that is the difference between
um a credit card that can't just run a
balance for six right
they charge crazy amounts of interest
they actually won't allow you to keep
the card
because you know that's the way that it
works and always
know the type of card you're getting
that's a whole other conversation
but going and being able to put the
things that you know are going to need
to get paid every month
on a card and then paying it off on
autopay you build
your credit you're showing your
consistency and then also you acquire
points
so when you get to that point of
understanding what you are looking for
in life like getting the difference
between getting
an everyday card that helps you because
you buy a lot of groceries or gas and
you get percentage back and
things like that it really helps i've
been able to do so much
with the like i have so many points now
and that's how a lot of rich people
honestly how a lot of rich people
do so many of the things that they do is
that they have traveling traveling
they have points what i like to think of
it as is lowering your
basis in your cost of living because
you're already
spending that money on things that you
have to pay for and then
you're getting points back on and then
you can use those points on stuff that
you would normally have to pay for
like flights and hotels and stuff you're
getting them for free
so you're saving all that money so
you're two people with the same exact
income
can live completely different lives
depending on how they're managing their
money and i think it's
it's so crazy to look at yeah people
might not understand how
that happens like why do you get [ __ ]
for free i don't understand it's because
a large pop a large part of the
population
is using these credit cards and and
running a balance and not paying it off
so they're making a [ __ ] ton of money so
like
you have to be the small percentage of
people who uses a credit card wisely
and that's why you like because a lot of
people are all want to get this flight
credit card but then they hold a balance
of 10 grand
right oh you're actually paying you know
you're just paying too much there
it's not it's not giving you any benefit
in the long run but if you're the person
that uses it wisely and you get the
points and you're actually
making money by not having these
expenses yeah
they they really they do this to you on
purpose like this is how they make their
money
this is why macy's is one of the first
cards that people get this is why
and they make sure not to teach you
about it unless you have yeah of course
because they're enticing the
dumb part of the population you know
once you learn what your interest
what your interest rates are holy [ __ ]
okay so
when you get to the point to where we
we've all definitely made credit card
mistakes i've definitely not paid all
the stuff that i needed to
on time i've not been as diligent as i
needed to be or i didn't have the funds
like sometimes i just didn't have the
money
and i was broke and i had to do certain
things and use a car
using your credit card as an emergency
fund rather than savings which
you're not supposed to do because we
know how that works out but
if you miss a payment the effects of it
is crazy let alone getting years yeah a
bill collector
negative marks last so long on your
credit score
and even here's another thing that they
don't really tell you about is when
you're looking to buy a car
even just looking to buy a car and they
run your credit score that's called a
hard inquiry
and those stay for about two years two
years about two years
that is a major negative mark that will
keep your credit score from
being where it should be you can pay all
your bills on time but you go and apply
for a new car that's the stupidest part
of
it the credit that i've ever yeah that
one i don't understand that i don't get
that one i'm just asking
yeah i'm just saying right there's hard
inquiries and then there's soft
inquiries
yeah so when you're looking to get a new
card that's a soft and it doesn't last
as long
but that's still going to be there and
then your total amount of credit history
is something that's taken into
consideration too i i'm a fan of um
credit karma yes same and it's not
exactly spot on just like
you have to fully understand that it's
not spot-on it's kind of like a guide
it's a general
um idea and it really simplifies
kind of what credit is and there's a lot
of suggestions on there we didn't have
that when we were younger it's a good
educational tool
yeah and a lot of other credit cards
have one too like credit karma capital
one
credit capital credit wise i feel that
with the amount of information that we
have access to you can't [ __ ] people
no more
like if you really are just out there
making poor financial decisions
in your like earlier years it carries on
it does not go away
you can have so much money and be poor
like you can be
have a job where you're making six
figures and you're in debt i know lots
of people like that
right now have no idea they have nice
things they have all this stuff but they
don't have a house
and and again even having owning a home
is its own conversation like do you want
it
especially in california it's like so
expensive hard
you could pay off your whole house and
the property taxes are still the cost of
some people's mortgages
in the country it's absolutely absurd
talking to people
and like homeowners yeah you have
problems
yep we all have problems actually we got
we got a lot of problems
in this group especially now i mean with
the whole
lockdown and everything now is a good
time to take care of your mental health
if you're feeling overwhelmed right now
then you're a human being and that's
okay
there's a whole lot to be anxious about
uh that's why we have talkspace
talkspace is making therapy affordable
and accessible for all basically
talkspace is an app where you get
connected to a real
therapist a licensed therapist you go on
there
you answer the questions they have i
think there's a bunch of questions that
ask like what
what do you want to work on what do you
want to talk about what is the
uh topics that you want to work on and
they will match you
with a therapist or they'll match you
with a few therapists and you choose
from which one you want to speak to you
get to see all the credentials how long
they've been
in the business and stuff so you talk to
them and then
the best thing about it is you can
switch therapists anytime you want
because you want to find the right one
for you
we all need extra support to feel our
best talkspace has thousands of licensed
therapists trained in over 40
specialties including anxiety
depression relationships and more no
matter what talkspace will find you the
right therapist to help you achieve your
goals
the best part about it is that it is
very very affordable
uh talk space is a fraction of the cost
of one in-person therapy i know this
i've done both
so the monthly fee for just talk space
is literally the price of one session
for an in-person
therapist talk space is also secure and
private you can put a password on there
every time you log in so no one's gonna
be snooping into your problems
talking to my friends is very different
from talking to a licensed therapist who
has
the expertise and knowledge to give me
practical guidance
talkspace gives us the support we need
at an affordable price
as a listener of this podcast you get a
hundred dollars off your first month
with talkspace to match with a licensed
therapist today go to talkspace.com
or download the app make sure you use
the code mood to get a hundred dollars
off your first month
and show your support for the show
that's mood and talkspace.com
alright guys in 2021 don't just make a
commitment to wash your hands every time
you poop
go the extra mile and wash your butt
it's a new year
new you so make sure you also have a new
clean rear for the new clean you in 2021
the future of toileting has arrived
okay actually it's been around for
centuries but it's been usually very
expensive
now the brand new hellotushy 3.0 modern
bidet attachment is here to level the
playing field it's a stylish
eco-friendly
easy to install and affordable device
hellotushy 3.0
doesn't just cleanse your butt with the
precise stream of fresh water
it cleans itself before and after it's
used with the smart spray
automatic self-cleaning nozzle it
attaches right to your existing toilet
with no
electricity or additional plumbing
needed
and it cuts your toilet paper use by
eighty percent
so it'll pay for itself very fast
because with hellotushy you don't wipe
it all
you just poop spray it off dab a little
dry
and go sanitation is simple
the schmutz shield offers easy cleaning
and the knobs are naturally
anti-microbial
every hello toshiba day comes with a
60-day risk-free guarantee and a
12-month warranty
if you've already got hello tushy on
your toilet upgrade to the new 3.0 model
if you're new to the revolution join
millions of happy hello tushy customers
right now and have a clean butt with
every flush
go to hellotushy.com slash big mood to
get
10 percent off plus free shipping this
is a special offer for our listeners so
go to hellotushy.com
big mood for 10 percent off that's
hellotushy.com
big mood when you use our code you
support the show
thank you very much it's kind of scary
and also don't feel forced to have to
buy a home either it's kind of
you know renting is better for some
people financially yeah
i mean if you i own a home but um
i've been i read a lot of david ramsey
and dave ramsey talks about
like only purchasing things in cash or
if you are going to take a loan on the
house
do a 15-year mortgage which is like it
saves
you it's more monthly but it's only a
couple hundred more a month
and then in interest you're cutting it
in half
the compound interest over 30 years
versus 15 years oh yeah
huge oh yeah i live in a million dollar
house if you can if you
incorporate all the interests that i'm
writing it's insane
so it's crazy it's almost like as adults
you should hit a certain age and
get emailed a damn uh book of turks
oh yeah like there should be things the
reason why
our economy runs away it runs off of
ignorance it runs honestly the
consumerism and stuff
and not just that but like the our
economy is built on the backs of the
poor
right and and it's exactly it's you know
it's built on the backs of the poor the
banks
take they totally take advantage how
strange is it that if you don't have
money you overdraw
and you get charged money that you don't
have and not just like
if you overdraw but like on every
transaction that you overdrew on that
you get a
lot of times you can call in and be like
can you please reverse some of these
charges
sometimes ain't nobody tell you about
like nobody tells you that you actually
can negotiate i didn't know that until i
did i called them and i was crying and i
was like i got in charge
seven times 35 and i i only had 200
in my account and i was like all of my
money is gone i don't have the money to
pay this how am i gonna pay you guys
three hundred dollars back
it doesn't hurt to ask it doesn't and
and that's that's another thing too like
pride pride's a [ __ ] that [ __ ]
will have you out here
uh paying way more than you need to and
it's like going and buying a car i think
that's a great example
of the the way that they take advantage
of people and what they don't know
yeah and how the closed mouths if you
you know if you don't ask you don't know
and really people get ripped off on cars
more than
any other purchase all the time but even
when you have medical bills
you can actually talk to the financial
department and work out a plan
your student loans you can work out a
plan um your credit cards you can work
out plans uh bill collectors
and if you ever fall into a situation
where you are dealing with
a debt collector they will negotiate
deals because they just want their money
and it's crazy what you can end up
fixing but the point is to never get to
get there yeah don't get to that point
don't get there you can
if you can avoid it but if you find
yourself in that situation which office
oh were you nervous to pick up the phone
you don't know who's calling you you
know you don't have the money
i somehow negotiated that though so
you're getting called all the time right
because like they're trying to collect
their debts
i cried and i just had a level
conversation with this chick and i think
she just related to me
because i was getting into massive
amounts of debts because i went through
a breakup and i couldn't
he was paying half the rent but my name
was on the lease so he moved out and now
i had to pay the full rent
and so i was just like leveling with her
like yo
i got dumped and like he left just give
me like six months like it's gonna take
me six months not
every other week and she i don't know
what she did she put my name on a magic
list or something
i never got called a kid she like
deleted your number yeah
she was like oh it's so sweet so shout
out to you yeah whoever that girl was
is not likely to happen for everyone no
but right i wouldn't have known if i
didn't ask
true you know i just treated her nicely
too it wasn't like mean like
i was just like hey i'm so sorry i
really want to pay you
this happened to me and like if you look
at my history i pay every month on time
but i'm in a situation where it's just
not going to happen
right and once you've gone through that
experience you kind of realize there's a
lot that people can
do yeah a lot of rich people don't pay
for a lot of [ __ ]
not at all example number one our
president
if you know anything about his finances
he doesn't pay for a lot of [ __ ] that's
insane
yeah businesses can write off bad debt
that's that's just built into the system
there's a thing called bad debt they can
write off debt that they cannot collect
and they expect to write off debt that
they cannot collect so if you call in
and be like hey i'm
i am bad debt yeah i need you to write
this off
you know having your own llc
understanding your businesses nobody
really teaches us about our taxes
we could make so many videos on this if
you had like if any of these are hitting
with you let us know in the comments
because we'll do separate videos and
dive into all of these
it's it's crazy because each one we
are all supposed to know about but we're
never taught
these are the basic fundamental things
as we find out the hard way
if our parents weren't able to do that
like uh my
my mom has great credit now but i
totally remember
the multiple cards and needing to figure
out how we're gonna pay for something
and then
understanding or even knowing what ebt
is and and knowing how to apply like i
was uh
when we moved to california we were on
wic and that's uh women and children
and so so we were on wic we had food
stamps back before ebt so
you know a lot of those things and those
programs are there to help people and
what's
the craziest part about california is
middle class isn't what we think it is
rich isn't what we think it is and poor
isn't what we think it is and
in order to just get basic help the way
that everything works is not
it's not easy and it's not really made
for us to understand
and there are so many designed that way
you know it was really designed
for us to not know how to take care of
generational and it's on purpose
yeah and same with rich like if you
don't have someone in your family that's
made a bunch of money
and can pass down their knowledge to you
you're gonna have to learn all this [ __ ]
the hard way
yeah and if you are out there being
bitter at rich
people who help their families stay rich
and teach their kids finances and they
still become successful and take over
the business like you just need to start
learning those things yourself so you
can teach your children
what generational wealth is and build
that for them because there are some
broke
there are some broke rich kids they're
poor they've [ __ ] their money away and
they
aren't cause that's what i'm saying
adversity helps you like really
maintain it like knowing your why and
the mindset i think it all starts with
mindset in your relationship
totally if you're what i did like going
through times of being poor and trying
to figure out what bill to pay first
yeah me hyper aware of my finances to
the point where like
i make sure i have that money now
because i understanding that struggle
means that you never want to feel it
again and you're gonna do whatever it
takes to not feel that anymore
totally like if we all had a thousand
dollars right now in our hands and said
this is all you get for the month figure
it out
oh we're going to be great at this you
know how are we going to how are we
going to do this
you know we're going to turn it into 10
000. right and or some or
it could be like you know some people
might be like oh no i'm not going to be
able to eat so they're thinking of
their like their physical body first
before anything else and then the
money's gone they're like they just got
groceries or if you have a
fear of losing money like your sister
might like stash it away
and report it right i am definitely like
a money hoarder and i had to learn how
to invest and that's what i'm learning
how to do now is to invest the money
because it's
terrifying to think oh yeah i can tell
when you're money
there's nothing you can touch it's
really a scary thing but
the magic of compound interest is
incredible
and if you are young listening right now
if i'm talking like 20
to if you're under 25 right now
listening
start [ __ ] putting your money
away and investing it because
you are gonna thank yourself later you
have time on your side
advantage yeah time is like the number
one ingredient to making your money work
for you
unless you have a huge capital to start
out with yeah then you're you're fine
again it's like figuring out what you
can put aside you know you have to build
to the point to where you can even have
a savings
do you have a rule for you i put away 10
no matter what
i unfortunately you know one of the
things was i put my six months aside
yeah and once i put my six months aside
i pretty much was living check to check
for a while
because i chose uh first i i i chose
a job you know doing i got a radio and
the job that i was at it's not a very
high paying job and especially in
california if you're not making six
figures you're like
you're you're pr you're struggling let's
be real right rent is expensive cost of
living is high taxes
so i um wasn't able to save currently
i kind of i know what's in my account
i'm paying my bills were good i haven't
been able to add too much more to my
savings yeah but i had my six months
which let's see that's perfect i had
built my six months which
let me be comfortable yes with taking a
job that's not as
high paying in order to build a longer
career i could make those sacrifices
but then i started you know fortunate
enough to have conversations like this
with uh with friends that are genuinely
interested
i mean me and your husband talk about uh
bitcoin bitcoin yeah
i mean i'm really like you know i was on
jk and i we were on the side and i was
saying you know what's going on this is
what i have
what else are we looking at and and did
you say you had a whole bitcoin
idea yeah that's worth a lot now how
much the whole bitcoin now
it's at 15 000 000. yeah and we're
looking to be projected
uh hope i mean fingers crossed a lot of
it we you know
don't know what it's going to do i mean
essentially like you're totally [ __ ]
yeah no one really knows and we can
pretend we know as much as
as we want to say that we know but we
try to predict you can base off trends
but you can't
really can't but you know hopefully by
the end of the year we're looking at 20
000 which is the same that hit in 2017.
and it was just at 11 000 like a month
ago yeah so
that was really frustrating yeah i was
trading sideways for a while and a lot
of people
you know what happened they linked up
with paypal yeah
but then when you go with into the whole
paypal thing and it just
learning about stocks puts you into
stocks and crypto
yeah it teaches you about the world yeah
you have to know what's going on
start to get hard yeah and it's crazy
what's going on in other countries and
you really have to learn how to live
outside your bubble you do understand
you know how some of your parents are
like there's people starving over there
and you and
some people don't really have the
concept of what it is to be poor or to
understand
how decisions in other places yeah a lot
of poor people have been complaining but
they have two tvs in their house right
now
you got a running refrigerator you got
hot water like you go to these other
countries and
poor is a different thing there is very
different yeah and
we we know what we have and it's not to
brag or to be like oh you need to be
you know oh that's terrible that you
bought this or you bought that it's like
no just being aware of what's happening
i believe i used to be poor right like i
lived in a shelter
i i was dead dirt [ __ ] poor i know
that
like i'm not poor anymore i'm not rich
i'm not wealthy by any [ __ ] means but
i used to be poor i know what poor looks
like right to be so desperately poor
and i will say that poor people do make
bad decisions with
money because it's an emotional thing
and i didn't say that as someone with
experience not as a rich person
looking down on poor people yeah i was
there i made bad choices because i
didn't know
because you're sad like you're sad yes
there's you're like i don't care that
i'm spending a hundred dollars on pizza
with the for the kids because we just
need something to be happy about
like we just want to have a fun party
and it's like i'm already [ __ ] anyway
yeah yeah who cares but that's one of
those things that gave me goosebumps
because i totally remember like like my
parents having to make those decisions
like
we lived in a house with 13 other people
at one point in time my parents did what
was best for us they moved us to a small
town where
we were you know sacrificed a job and
sacrificed other things so that we could
live and have better opportunities they
wanted me to grow up with an education
and they wanted me to grow up
in a safer environment so they put me in
bum [ __ ] middle of nowhere
but they sacrificed my mom worked two
jobs she worked her way into what she
had my dad
you know was a stay-at-home dad and and
there's certain things that i'll always
appreciate that money can't buy money
can't buy the time that my dad was able
to give me
and money can't buy the fact that my mom
was a boss instead stepped up
to make sure that we were good i had
working women around me
yeah and and we were able to see what it
is to balance a household that's awesome
and to be broke you know like there are
certain things that you just
experience that make you who you
are but you you look at your parents and
it gives me it really does give me
goosebumps because of the struggle
um you look at your parents and you go i
know that
one day i may experience stuff like this
yep and i'll know how to handle it right
and i'll know how to be with my children
with it
you know finances a lot of the times our
parents have done our their best to
shelter us or they were straight up i
knew we didn't have money
there was no way around it it was no
but we want you to play sports my dad
cooked at every damn
sporting event he had his little hibachi
grill out and was catering
so i can play but there was a lot of
things that you give up and you you
learned that you have to answer to
somebody
yeah so the goal was to never be in that
situation again so
building businesses like you talking
about your merge it takes money
and a strong belief system to go
out and do something like that it does
take money to make money that's
that's not going to be knowing the
difference between investing and
spending like or making money too a lot
of people are like i guess i gotta cut
back all these but how about also think
about
making more yeah
yeah multiple streams of income is a
must especially in these days
um so if you don't have that think about
it think about ways to build multiple
streams
passive income is is the goal
that's how you get to multiple streams
yeah and in the beginning it'll look
like this where you're putting a lot of
time in and not making a lot of money
but then over time
you give that compounding interest and
and multiple streams and passive income
you start working less and you get a lot
more money
the man the amount of information that
we have in our hands now
it's it's crazy you know we used to
believe that you had to go to school
you got to get a degree you had to have
a student for certain careers you do no
not shaming college no no but that's all
we knew yeah
know of other opportunities and it was
more ashamed if you didn't do that
definitely and and getting into other
fields or going into like a vocational
school which is
brilliant for some people you know the
the rule of thumb back in the day was it
is ten thousand hours and you know why i
was that right
so in order to be like a smit uh like a
a smith and build something
you would essentially intern with a
master in a mat in order to become a
master you need ten thousand hours of
work
so we used to intern essentially and
work for somebody for free
so that we can have that job one day so
that's why vocational school is so
important because you get the skills
right there then we started going to
universities and
it blows my mind how expensive it is
people are in debt forever because of
these student loans
it's supposed to be an investment like
and back in the day it kind of made
sense
yeah yeah like the amount you put in you
are you're making that back within a few
years
right but now it it's just i'm
mad at more of a round at how much
they're getting taken advantage of
and that the government stepped in
because like it shouldn't be
that the government's making money off
of this i i
wish that i would have been able to go
to a better school i wish i had
more degrees under my belt i wish i had
the
not even like the luxury but i wish i
had the
the finances to know that i can go into
this and not be poor
coming out of it you know i want to
constantly learn and it's great that we
have like online schooling now and that
can help us teach us about finances
instead of having to enroll into a
university
to learn about finances and even going
on youtube it's crazy there's so many
videos for free yeah so many sources out
there you know we're learning
that right now the way that the banking
system is having a savings account may
not even be the best thing for you in a
bank
and that's crazy to think because you
know some people are taught you want to
have
a 401k and you need your savings and you
need this and you need that
but when you start learning about what's
happening in the world we have negative
interest right now
which is not good for you to have your
money in the bank
as far as just sitting and sitting there
um for liquidity
purposes like i would say the six month
income that you have set aside
put it in a high high high yield it's
quote unquote high yield it's not high
anymore it's like a half percent
yeah it's like point five percent um but
at least you're making
a some money on your money yeah uh it's
not gonna keep up with inflation but
uh purpose of that chunk is just to be
it's just emergency
but yeah if you have that locked in the
rest of it the rest of it though
no yeah and it really sucks when you get
like a job job i remember when i got my
like
first job job and i had a 401k and i'm
like
oh my god okay such an adult here's the
thing i had no [ __ ] clue what that
was
just it just sounded everyone has one
and i have one now right i'm like oh i'm
grown i get a check
i used to get mad because i was like my
final paycheck was so small because i
was like
taxes insurance 401k and then i'm left
with this what the [ __ ] am i doing
and then you have to learn what that is
and i can't catch it till i'm 65 why
right and then there's penalties if i
try to take out money
it's so wild that these are our every
day
this is our everyday vocabulary that
most of us don't
understand what is happening on a daily
basis like um
my aunt was looking at her check the
other day and she was
looking at the amount of taxes that
we're taking out and she was just
[ __ ]
her mind was like so much of you to be a
w-2
worker is so sad in california
and then to you know say we're
struggling because right now we're
talking about
pretty much the come up figuring out
how to maximize rat and understanding
the struggle some of your friends are
going to be
living their lives in a way that you
don't know what what's happening with
their finances
it might look like someone's doing way
better than they are but you don't know
if they're just putting that [ __ ] on
credit they're massive amounts of debt
um another like the best piece of advice
i got when i was younger
was to pay yourself first no matter if
you're
a w-2 or if you're self-employed or you
have an llc or whatever
pay yourself first because why should
the why should the government get paid
all their all the bills get paid
everyone gets paid but you
so that's where the concept of ten
percent came from and i kept that rule
because
it's like i worked for this money i
should get to keep a piece of it and
whether it's ten percent or five percent
or two percent or whatever it is
just a set amount of money that when i
get a check immediately i subtract that
amount and it goes to me
and it goes away and nobody else sees it
and then i pay my bills and everything
and so
when i'm going through the income and
expenses if
i take that 10 percent first and i don't
have enough money left over for all the
bills and stuff
i need to figure out how to cut back on
the other expenses or i need to figure
out how to make more money
because i am still getting paid that 10
percent totally and
that helps with investing too because
that's all going to go towards investing
or savings
have you guys ever had um like we're in
a relationship with somebody who was
financially irresponsible
yeah responsible no
i'm very careful with who i choose and
if it's if they are irresponsible about
it
i make it a point to it's not like i'll
i'll
pay for dinner help you here and there
but i'm not gonna you know
yeah i had a guy who tried he's like can
you co-sign a a lot for me i'm like no
absolutely not no don't co-sign yeah
yeah anyone yeah unless you can just
pretty much expect to be paying for that
thing
unless you want to own it yeah yeah
don't go sign it
he asked me to co-sign a loft and bmw
i'm like no darling jesus
yeah if you need a co-sign for a bmw you
don't
da you start yeah what is not your time
i think wasn't that great and you can
calm down with it like
chill chill get the monster truck we
know you're compensating but
uh if you can't buy it twice you can't
afford it yeah that's the rule that i
live by too if you can't buy it twice
you can't afford it it's uh you can pay
for it but doesn't mean you can afford
it yeah
yeah there's a lot of that or if you
can't buy it in cash
yeah oh yeah another little i don't
think i would just drop
75 grand on my cars maybe i can't afford
it but i can
i can pay the payments yeah one of one
of the other little tricks that i was
taught
you know pain in cash there there's so
much leverage that you have when you pay
in cash
um i bought my whole my couch
my california king bed the bed frame the
mattress the side tables a dresser with
the mirror for two thousand dollars
there's like five grand worth of [ __ ]
two thousand dollars in cash and
delivery
over 50 miles away for two thousand you
can get a lot of discounts when you pay
things
like full cash in cash and everything is
you can negotiate everything that is
like the closed mouth don't get fed
there
you can negotiate everything your car
your
medical your bill if you're paying cash
in medical like a lot of
even if you have insurance sometimes
it's just cheaper to pay cash yeah
always keep it always if you're making
any big purchases always keep a set
amount of cash because you can negotiate
it down a lot because we don't think
about the fact that the
the vendors are paying somebody
for you to use your card so they get
charged
so if you're saving them money yeah they
don't want to pay
their money they just want their money
well also they want they want cash now
too because
cash now is worth more than cash flow
yeah same with gold jewelry like a lot
of things
that's one of the one of the biggest
gems is that
when you want to go and buy something
keep that cash on hand just in case
because you can always negotiate yes you
are the king cash is king
so we could talk about this for [ __ ]
ever i'm gonna leave it at this
if if there's one takeaway that you got
from this it's
don't spend more than you earn well i
guess this is more than one take away
but also have that savings and um put
away 10
of your income and if you want to learn
what to do with that 10
as far as investing goes it could be a
separate episode
let us know if there's anything else you
would want us to do an episode about
because we could talk forever day don't
spend money to show off
when you don't have it yeah don't and
then don't always just work to pay your
bills
use work to help fund your dreams yeah
that's investing in yourself
always invest in yourself and give us
thumbs up
we like it check out our merch check out
gina's merch check out all of nick's go
to nicki's
stuff yes actually my merch
it might already be out by the time yeah
nikki street eats nikki blades
everything
everyone follow yeah check me love her i
love you
bye thanks guys thanks for having me